let's uh let's jump over the first story
the story about prosecutors this is from
wtop news this is a local dc
prosecutor's way heavy hammer felony
murder for rioters and capital officers
death
they say as federal prosecutors filed
charges against rioters who took part
in last wednesday's violent takeover the
u.s capitol investigators continue to
gather evidence in the death of capitol
police officer brian siknik
who died from injuries sustained during
the attack while most murder
investigations
folk um focus on the person or persons
who caused the fatal injury
former federal prosecutor tim heaphy
said prosecutors could charge many
rioters with felony murder even if they
were nowhere near sicknick
heaphy led the month-long investigation
to law enforce law enforcement
performance before
during and after the deadly 2017 uh
rally in charlottesville
heaphy was in the u.s attorney for
western district of virginia from
december 09
through january 2015 appointed by obama
under the doctrine of felony murder
which applies in the district of
columbia any murder that occurs during
the commission
of one of several underlying felonies is
chargeable as felony murder saying quote
the classic example is if three guys go
to rob a convenience store
and one guy is the getaway driver if in
the commission of the robbery the clerk
was shot and killed all three of the
participants in the robbery of the store
are potentially guilty of felony murder
on january 6 as most of you know there
was a raucous event at the capitol
some call it an insurrection some call
it a riot some called storming they say
in the federal murder code
11 underlying felonies which can be part
of of a felony murder murder charge are
listed
one which could be applicable to the
january 6 takeover is burglary
quote you could look at the storming of
the doors of the capitol by that riotous
mob as burglary
if they went in with the intent to steal
disrupt proceedings to commit other
offenses
they committed burglary and therefore a
murder that occurred during the course
of a burglary
could be potentially charged as felony
murder the mere act of breaking
the capital doesn't constitute burglary
uh prosecutors would need to prove that
they intended to do something criminal
once they were inside
let's say somebody storms the capital
with the intent to disrupt congress
or steal the sign outside of speaker
pelosi's door and there's a murder that
occurs in the midst of that
he could be charged with felony murder
as with any crime federal or state
prosecutors have to weigh
whether charges can be sustained in
court they say in this case with crimes
committed on federal property
and then in the death of a federal
employee the us attorney for the
district of columbia
which prosecutes cases in both federal
and local courts would have the felony
murder count at its disposal so i'll say
this
it wasn't just the officer who died it
was ashley babbitt
i think they if if they go this route
and they could i i'm not entirely sure
they will
they could actually charge these people
maybe even every single person who went
in the building
with the death of ashley babbitt because
a death occurred in the commission of a
crime
there's a lot of things that are crazy
about this there have been photos
popping up of random people who are
like well i mean most people are kind of
random in a sense but some people who
weren't even in the building
people are doxing them and saying they
were there that's enough that's all that
matters some people who weren't in the
building at all
and in the case of the new york times we
just mentioned this richie mcginnis
who's been on the show several times
who's a journalist
he's actually the journalist who tried
to save the life of the man who was shot
in kenosha wisconsin earlier this year
he's he's up against a window
pointing down and the new york times
were in a caption saying that he was a
rioter who punched the glass
when they wouldn't let him in which is
just not true he dropped his phone and
he was trying to ask someone to pick it
up for him
so this is where things get weird if
they actually i guess the question is
are they going to go after all of the
trump supporters with an iron fist
when you look at black lives matter and
how the district attorneys were
releasing these people and not charging
them
there's a question of whether or not
they're going to be biased against
conservatives and just
run them through the you know run them
over the coals throw the book at them or
are they going to be worried about you
know potentially setting off some kind
of
political spark by going for trump
supporters in this way
um i think a couple things one
this whole felony murder thing is an
overreach in in the worst way
because when you talk about
three or four people robbing a
convenience store it's all coordinated
it's all planned they they are in
cahoots with each other
all the people that stormed the capital
they didn't know each other were they on
were they all on parlor and saying hey
let we're we're going to do this
particular thing they didn't even know
these people didn't even know each other
so you can't say that
or or the person that that shot david
doran do you go well everybody who was
committed
who was part of the riot is complicit
you can't say that that's the question
of bias all right well here he wouldn't
do that for
the riots and black with black lives
matter would they do it here well that's
different
it it's it's it's a different story too
because you're talking about district
attorneys on a local level on a state
level
now with since this happened on federal
property you're talking about
the doj and the up the incoming doj
so you're probably not going to see your
it's all this talk about charges
but you're not going to see anything
really come about until
after biden is not exactly yeah unless
unless trump comes out and just sweeping
pardons everybody
i i actually made a joke on my twitter
about that i think it's gonna happen uh
no
it won't but uh well yeah because trump
doesn't have anything but it could be
but that that would be
that would be kind of a bold move
wouldn't you say well another thing to
really kind of understand here i
remember seeing someone post
and saying well it's good to see that
the fbi could be effective
when they want to be and we have to
admit the fbi has been pulling out all
the stops there's videos of them
of showing up at people's homes stopping
people at airports they're putting up
signs on bus stops
so they're doing everything in their
power and utilizing all of their power
in an extensive way which seems like
they're activated in a way that they
weren't before
and if we're going to look at
responsibility i mean there's already
some investigations going around the
capitol police there's some officers
suspended
but wasn't it wasn't there six requests
that were denied for extra police
assistance by the mayor's office
no no no not by the mayor's office it
was by uh capitol police
by the capitol police six times they got
denied the the mayor
this is really interesting muriel bowser
was according to new york times
concerned about
having an excessive police presence
following a summer of riots and the
criticism of over policing
she was like i don't want it we want
limited you know national guard just
guiding traffic and some police
and so she said a narrow unarmed mission
that's crazy six times they asked they
said we need more police for this and
they're like nah
well see that's that's the thing um when
you read twitter and everybody goes
didn't you see this coming we saw this
coming we all saw coming you're like
well the mayor didn't the the black
mayor
of washington dc didn't so if she didn't
then well she put out a statement on the
fifth saying like i'll make it clear i
am not requesting a strong police
presence right
it's the it's the aftermath of saying
defund the police man
the politicians get scared and they're
like all right all right let's let's
let's hold back because we don't want
like think about it after painting black
lives matter in the street
renaming the plaza and then saying i
want a battalion of jack boots marching
through the streets locking everything
down
people she she would get roasted by the
left so she's like nope nope
and now she's gonna get roasted by the
left no matter what but she was already
being roasted by the left when she went
out of her way she made sure that the
street
said black lives matter there was
another argument because they wanted
more she didn't want to give it to them
but
we have something somebody put defund
the police next to it yeah and they like
washed it off
yeah and then some people are being
charged with hate crimes for for
putting out you know similar messages
but in a different kind of political
uh understanding but another thing to
really kind of
we really kind of really think here
along the lines of everything that
that's unfolding we have to understand
this is extremely
political when we have someone in a
prosecutor's office when we have someone
appointed as attorney
general and we have george soros given
them millions of dollars there's a
reason he's investing so much money
because
you not only get political favors but
you're able to kind of sweep
the landscape of our society in ways
that laws can't
because when you choose how you to
enforce laws and this is the selective
enforcement of it to the highest degree
when you see it done this way it is ah
stunning to see what they could get away
with you know what's funny uh
shuan had posted his tweet where she was
like
it's a screenshot of parlor being
removed and she said rightos
this is what bezos has taken from you
let's redistribute his wealth as as like
revenge or whatever
and i i just thought it was really funny
and i'm like i'm okay with this i
look i'm not really okay with the idea
of like seizing the wealth of everybody
and just spreading it around
there's a problem with corporate power
and government power when it exceeds
certain levels
but when you have someone like bezos who
has so much money and
mackenzie base specifically putting
billions of dollars
into left-wing political causes it's
creating instability
so there's certainly something to
complain about there but i think it's
funny you bring up you know the
influence people get when they buy
politicians
which they basically do and there's
really no like i don't know if there's a
way we actually stop
that process but there is i think a left
and the right
like left and right could come together
on this and be like yo these people are
subverting
our institutions and that's a problem
well you also speaking of parlor you'll
you'll also never
guess um the washington post
put out uh the editorial board put out
an opinion piece
uh about parlor you'll you'll never
guess what their opinion was
it's a good thing it was it was a good
thing yeah it was a good thing
our boss did the right thing basically
yeah right right yeah we're seeing
because amazon
uh [ __ ] owns the washington post
well we're seeing a lot of flip-flopping
let's be honest here we're seeing a lot
of people flip from their
original ideas of defunding to police to
now the police are great
and actually and there's even some
individuals arguing that ashley babbitt
deserved it
that's the that's the laugh those people
are sick yes and when you're making
arguments like that after having months
of protest against the police
and now you're supporting the police you
really have to start asking yourself
what's going on here and these
flip-flops happen
not just within the left they happen
within the right in some instances but
right now we are seeing this kind of
shifting of of basic kind of
virtues overnight because of political
power
because of wanting your side to win
because of gang affiliation which is
more important than the truth to many
people
let me say something george floyd should
not have died
brenda taylor should not have died
ashley babbitt should not have died
it is a tragedy when any person loses
their life
you know i was saying it earlier i don't
care if you committed a crime
you know i don't want you to die i
understand there are circumstances where
someone could be violent and dangerous
and only
in the process of trying to preserve
life do we end someone else's life
that's self-defense that's why
that's why we allow that as a as a
defense in court or as a reason not to
prosecute somebody
but to see antifa say that a person who
has shot
an unarmed person shot by a cop deserved
it
wow talk about the utmost
hypocrisy now listen when i saw those
conservatives
throwing the blue lives matter on the
ground and stomping on it that to me
looked
more like anger and kind of a
realization
as to what they were experiencing and it
was it was for a lot of
the conservatives who were you know
being basically shut down by these cops
they've never had this happen before
because conservatives don't protest for
the most part
so to them it was kind of like this new
experience where they were like dude are
you kidding me
this is ridiculous what they're doing so
they stomped on that flag that's not
hypocrisy
that's a change of opinion to an extent
i can respect antifa changing their
opinion if their opinion was consistent
they're saying an unarmed woman who was
shot by a cop deserved it
okay all right so the guy with the taser
shooting at cops that's you know
they're saying that the fascist us
government killing an unarmed woman
is justified antifa defending
what they pre what they claim to be
fascist we're going into a very scary
time where policies no longer matter and
only power matters
and when you go towards this this
particular
instant of where we're at right now
we're going to see people leveraging
that power and trying to use that power
to try to hurt
their political opposition and and i
think that's where we are right now with
people trying to take advantage
and and escalating threats and and
fear-mongering about them to to really
rattle the their base to support this
kind of emergency takeover of civil
liberties
because that's historically what always
happens you know regarding ashley
babbitt i
i don't support i'm not glad she's dead
but
they she was climbing through a window
into a sensitive area of the capitol
building with a few
armed guards that were terrified for
their lives and probably charged to
protect
things and people in there did you see
she had a footage she had a backpack on
so she could have a bomb in that and
that's probably what went through their
mind when they saw it i think they had i
think
you're supposed to defend the captain he
couldn't see her no that's right she
stuck her head up there's police
officers behind her
i know there's cops but listen i'll say
this i don't think that officer should
be criminally
charged he he it's his job to defend the
capital he's got politicians inside
and people were breaking the glass and
trying to break in and she pops up and
he fired
we can have it we can have a discussion
about administrative procedure due to
the fact that he fired on a person maybe
he fired too soon maybe he should have
waited maybe it was the right thing we
don't we can have the discussion
okay no criminal charges in my opinion
because yeah you you break your way into
the capital
she may have been part of the group that
they opened the door for we have no idea
maybe she was part of the group that
shoved their way in
but you have an unarmed person and a
bunch of bewildered and doting people
who
many of whom didn't know what was going
on like that old grandma lady waving
little flag coming right she clearly had
no idea what's happening
so so for this woman to get shot it's
tragic
i wish it didn't happen i don't blame
the cop i don't we saw criminal charges
for less for officers
uh right before which is also important
to bring up and and i mean
there should be an entire investigation
into what happened and
there should be a jury deciding what
what should happen from here but
i i don't think you're right ian uh
that's just my opinion
i mean it's it remember again you're
it's
this is so different because it's on a
federal level
yeah uh these people are not elected
these
you know the the uh attorney general
uh is not elected uh unlike say
keith ellison in minnesota he was
elected
you know uh the the the woman from st
louis
uh with the uh the mccluskies yeah right
yeah elected
and again george soros stuff so that's
it it's it's an entirely different
scenario and it's in it's
in in a way it's it's scarier on the
state level
because at least in the federal level
there's
well there's there should be less bias
but you know it
it it depends on who you pick that's why
this part of this private police
conversation starts is freaking me out
we have a lot of people in here that are
like and capped to the extreme where
it's like no
no public service we want private police
only like a private policeman can shoot
you dead
well well it depends i mean if you make
the argument for detroit to detroit
implemented private police and they had
positive results because of that
uh and and you know you really get into
a big argument here that
it's kind of taken away from the kind of
conversation because there's still
uh just so many other things that we
could delve into but i understand both
sides of the argument here we do have
some breaking news though
trump has declared a state of emergency
in dc ahead of biden's inauguration
it's quite a simple story it's really
just donald trump approved it they said
they want to declare a state of
emergency in dc there's threats against
the inauguration trump says
yes so it'll be interesting to see what
happens in the next uh
nine days or so they're saying armed
armed protestant capitals
uh armed protests in dc who knows what
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you